[Music]
I I went to one more video because I
think you guys can learn this this week
and that's to beat leaves so it's a lot
like what we were learning of crossing
both arms but now it's going to be a
split time pattern and it's going to be
an important lead up to the three beat
weaves and also it's a very important
pattern for all kinds of cool moves and
you can actually do an incredible amount
of stuff just to beat weeds because it's
kind of a can be a milling pattern but
you'll understand that later
grab your poi and face this way all
right face that way a lot we're gonna
face this way let's see you're gonna do
this right boy it's gonna lead so you're
going to start going past your right
foot so we're facing this way together
and you go right left and passing your
foot so right left then your right boys
going to come over the top crosses over
your left arm and then past your left
foot you go right left you come back
uncrossed right left cross right over
right left so it's the right thing on
both sides past your right foot arms or
uncrossed they have to cross to let the
right lead past your left foot let's go
right leads right leads and you're
letting your poi hang right these bright
beats right these right leads and you're
gonna slowly speed it up and what's
important that you make sure you always
make that cross because people otherwise
will do guys they go right leads and
then they can let their left lead and
that won't lead to the pattern so you
can go give it a bit of momentum go
right leads and cross and very naturally
the left will follow the right so you
don't have to worry about the left just
where you go right crosses over make
that cross you know go kaboom and the
right we'll look lead past your left
foot and they can come back so the
little practice it's gonna look like
this cross and back and cross and back
and cross and back and cross and
back and what's really important that
you're letting the body do this because
when you did same time crossing it's a
sort of a centerline symmetrical
movement so I can stand here stoic they
even let my plate cross together but for
this pattern the hands actually can stay
quite close that's just going to make it
look and feel good a lot of time so your
body has to bob and weave following the
hands so for this one when I pass the
right foot you turn to the right then
you cross the pass the left foot you
turn to the left left and right left
good same thing with the other hand
hanging out at the left lead so pass
your left foot the left is leading it
comes over the top and crosses over the
right arm to lead pass the right foot
then come back together left please pass
the left foot cross left leads pass the
right foot left foot cross right foot
left foot right foot left foot right
foot left foot right foot left foot
right foot left foot right foot and if
you are not making that cross it won't
work make it cross left make it cross
left foot right foot left foot right
foot right foot left foot and that's
your forward to belief mmm what I want
you to be able to do is to get into it
from just spinning the poi forward split
time so we can spin this way we just
pick a side let's pick our left foot
what's gonna happen is your right boy
it's gonna have to come over and chase
the left boy and the first time you can
just hit your arm to make sure you're
coming over to the plane over here come
back then you're gonna go over and cross
come over and cross over it over cross
over cross over cross over you're also
gonna do that on this side where the
left boy can come over to hit the right
arm just to make sure you're initiating
by bringing the poi to one side but and
once you're confident you can do
that but when you bring both point of
the right side the right can cross over
the left because otherwise you'll fall
back to this the muscle and it's gonna
look more like this and then cross the
right side left side right side left
side so what's important in all of this
is that you can do either one equally
comfortably um don't practice if you
keep practicing the easier one you'll
get this increasing Gulf in non symmetry
and that will mess with you later
so you want to make sure it's both ways
and always balance them so whichever one
you know by tomorrow feels harder
practice that one more the day after
tomorrow until you can go okay I'm gonna
bring my right boy to my left left over
left over left over back to split time
now I'm gonna bring my left boy to the
right side right over right over right
over and then ahead so you can go okay
start on my left left over start on my
right right over left over split time
right over split time start on the left
start on the right start and when
they're equal when you balance them
that's gonna let you come into the
continuous crossing of a full three beat
weave right over left Oh although I want
to stress that few betweens are awesome
and possibly even more versatile than
the three beat weaves but a lot of this
is just to be weeds right so what you're
not going to do is use the to beat
weaves just to learn the three beat
waves and then forget the to beat weeks
if that will give you forever as a place
better um but I think that's enough for
this lesson learning that we'll be
coming back to this you'll be having the
weaves in no time and then turn
[Music]